hey this is kind of a cool new thing the
David Pakman show is doing we are now
publishing our content to steam it and
that's with two e's ste e MIT steam it
is a platform that was created early
last year by Ned Scott and Daniel
Larimer and it's powered by blockchain
technology and it uses a new
cryptocurrency to reward users who
upload either articles images commentary
or an hour case we are doing david
pakman show video content and it's a
pretty interesting set up where users
are paid half in steam power which is a
vesting currency and half in steam
dollars which can be exchanged for US
dollars and both the content creator as
well as those who are I guess we could
call it voting or a better word would be
curating the best content on the
platform through their up voting of
content that they like the David Pakman
show is on steam it at steam it calm / @
symbol David Pakman ok ste EMI t.com / @
symbol David Pakman and I would love it
for you to join us over there we are
we've been looking since YouTube D
monetization actually at a number of
different platforms that we could expand
to there were dozens that I looked at
and considered and we are slowly
starting to pick some of our spots where
we are going to be publishing david
pakman show content and steam it is one
of them okay and I will have more news
for you about others as I have news I
will make it known to you but in the
meantime I would encourage you to check
out the david pakman show on steam it
steam it calm slash at David Pakman and
I'll have more information about this
for you probably before you know it